Atomic carlos says,
my Iq is north of one 30 yet I questioned
my own intelligence all the time.
I feel big cognitive dissonance between
what people expect of me and what I
considered myself capable to do.
Well,
you know Carlos would,
I would recommend there is that if,
if you haven't done it,
just go do the personality test and
understand myself.com because what you're
describing sounds very much like high
levels of negative emotionality or
neuroticism.
And you might want to find
out if that's the case,
because if you're much higher
than average in neuroticism,
then you're going to be
questioning yourself all the time.
And you might want to figure out if that's
actually a trait and if it is a trait
while then that gives
you an explanation of it.
And then you might also know that your
levels of negative emotion are not well
matched to your likely scale.
Now that doesn't necessarily
help you learn to cope with it,
but sometimes identifying the reason it's
useful and there's another possibility
too is that your mood is dysregulated
and that you're depressed.
So that's another thing to consider.
Um,
if you,
if you do find that you have high
levels of neuroticism but you're not
depressed,
then one of the things you might
do is write down all the reasons,
like really think them out.
You know what I mean?
Really get serious about this.
Write down all the reasons why you
might give yourself more credit for
intelligence than you have.
And part of that could be like a really
deep reconsideration of successes you've
had in the past with
complex intellectual issues.
Um,
because imagine that you are serving as
your own defense attorney against a very
critical part of your
mind that can help locked,
that can help.